[Applaudissements]
il a alors fait huit ponctuation pas si
c'est jean-marie entre deux tournées
semaine qui l'a pas baisé la trappe sa
famille de lalala vient jean-victor j'ai
envie de toi bien bien bien maintenant
la toxicité mais non chérie là c'est pas
possible parce que pardon mais je des
pertes blanches
hédi ben moi j'ai du diabète bien voir
des merengues
c'est une femme qui monte dans le bus
avec son bébé dans les mains et le
chauffeur de bus la voie avec son bébé
et ivoire butin je faire de bus il peut
pas s'empêcher il dira mais qu'est-ce
qu'il est moche qu'est ce qu'il est les
veaux des vérités que l'aston bébé là et
elle allait choquer à livet vin au fond
du bus en pleurs elle pleure à ça soit
que vous êtes quelqu'un est tout à
l'heure la personne à côté d'elle lui
dit mais pourquoi tu pleures comme ça et
ou non mais je ne me faire insulter par
le par le chauffeur de bus et fut
évasive à le voir avoir insulté aliot
est c'est vrai il lui a dit vous n'êtes
pas soit on singe je te le gardes alors
c'est ça marseille
tiens tu veux te dire j'adore marseille
1 bien sûr ma femme travaille là bas
oui et elle fait ma passe par jour si tu
brises 1 classe une casse tous les
élèves et vidéos sont de marseille la
cité dit quel sens qu'ils sont les
supporters de l'om et tout va bien c'est
oit sauf un dans le fond le petit
antoine
la cicatrice sur le 100 m avant d'y bas
à eux eu entrave
tu n'es pas supporter 2 2 l'om dit non
madame moi je suis supporter brestois
ah bon mais pourquoi diverses que mon
père et les supporters brestois
ma mère a les supporters brestoise et
mon frère et ma soeur sans supporters
brestois alors moi je suis supporter
brestois
ces tueries ces fins antoine tu as aussi
son libre arbitre quand même là tu
allais dire yves abrite 6 6 et coiffes
dame alors comme elle voit qu'il
comprend pas lui dit entrave je donne un
exemple plus simple imagine que ton père
soit un gros connard et ta mère une
soeur et un frère
soeur debra rien dit à ce moment là tu
serais quoi est atteint du liban craint
supporteurs de l'om
j'ai une dernière people et ça concerne
quelqu'un qui est autour de cette table
ce soir
non c'est qui un comique un peu en fin
de carrière je sais pas pourquoi
j'aurais pensé à moi tu verras c'est pas
si simple
alors qu'il n'assume pas du tout sa
calvitie alors il fouille un peu sur
internet pour essayer de trouver une
solution et dans les recettes de grand
mère et moi un truc sur une étape bien
le sperme sur le crâne ça peut repousser
les cheveux de type e devant moi c'est
déjà dur de parler de ça l'équivalent
salle de bain ce monsieur recueille 10
fermes et se couvrent le crâne au plus
mauvais moment sa femme rentre dans la
salle de bain qu'est ce que tu fais sans
déconner tu fais quoi
et voilà j'ai vu ça sur internet il
paraît que le sperme ça fait repousser
les cheveux et lui dit mais tu crois ces
conneries bah ouais j'ai cru elle dit
mecheri réfléchit depuis le temps qu'on
est ensemble urbain moustache
[Applaudissements]